in den niederlanden nämlich schon mal
auf diese bilder einmal da protestieren
die bauern seit wochen gegen strengere
umweltauflagen die für viele das aus
bedeuten und mit trackern mit häuser
setzten sie sich zu wehr riesige demos
und sie sehen selbst sogar waffen werden
teilweise eingesetzt es wird immer ist
es ist ein 16 jähriger war in würdet es
wird immer brutaler ist wird immer
aufgeheizter jetzt fielen sogar schüsse
wir haben hier nicht nur eine
politikerin sitzen sondern auch eine
landwirtin sind aufgewachsen auf einem
bauernhof sie betreiben den immer noch
sie sind also machen spagat zwischen den
sie sich wünschen von vielen politikern
zwischen das reale leben und der politik
und dieses thema geht ihnen ganz nah und
die große frage kann sowas auch bei uns
passieren ja dieses thema das
beschäftigt mich wirklich sehr stark
weil weil es mich so betrifft und ich
will mal ein relativieren die bauern
demonstrieren nicht gegen umweltauflagen
die deutliche demonstrieren um ihre
existenz um ihre daseinsvorsorge um das
was generationen aufgebaut haben das ist
der grund wer die landwirte auf die
straße treibt die hatten ja auch schon
glaubt bauernproteste hier vor einigen
jahren da ging es genau um das gleiche
thema und die frage die sie stellen kann
das auch hier passieren also ich habe
verständnis dafür wenn landwirte auf die
straße gehen um für ihre interessen zu
kämpfen ich habe kein verständnis für
gewalt das will ich auch ganz klar sagen
auch nicht von landwirten an der stelle
wir müssen auch normal miteinander
umgehen aber dass man erkennt dass wir
politik gemeinsam mit den landwirten
machen müssen und nicht gegen sie das
ist sehr sehr wichtig ich mache mir auch
große sorgen weil nämlich vieles so
teuer geworden ist bei uns und sicher
bei uns menschen mit mir leisten können
und geschichten basieren die sie gerade
eben schon dargestellt haben dass leute
im supermarkt dinge zurücklassen weil
sie es sich einfach nicht leisten können
das ist ne das ist eine debatte die wir
hier in europa haben aber bestehen
angriffskrieg und durch die
exportverbote die russland auch auf sein
eigenes getreide gemacht hat durch
getreide was auf dem fruchtbaren boden
der ukraine nicht mehr geahndet werden
kann hungern menschen auf der ganzen
welt und schon im letzten jahr hat wurde
davor gewarnt dass aufgrund der pandemie
folgen 80 millionen menschen mehr
hungern auf der welt das war vor dem
angriffskrieg in dieser woche wurde die
zahl nochmal erneuert noch mal um 40
millionen sind dazugekommen die mehr
hungern einfach dadurch dass
verknappungen stattfinden durch diese
man kann ja schon wirklich fast sagen
die ärzte das auch richtig sagt das ist
auch ein hunger krieg im endeffekt
geworden ist und das macht mir insgesamt
große sorgen weil unsere landwirte die
haut die kann ja was die haben das ja
gelernt das sind hier keine leute die
einfach mal anfangen so werden sie so
entsprechend auch geschätzt haben sie
das gefühl deutschland liegt auf seine
bauern bäuerinnen und bauern und sagt
hut ab ich glaube in sonntagsreden wird
es sehr geschätzt aber es kommt auch auf
partner an am ende des tages und
landwirte können was die können was
anbauen die können tatsächlich jetzt hat
die ernte angefangen dann sieht man
tatsächlich auch das ergebnis von harter
arbeit von einem jahr harter arbeit und
dann den menschen zu sagen mensch macht
weniger von dieser produktion die ihr ja
könnt und macht mehr sonst irgendwas ich
habe jetzt mal sehr provokativ gesagt
einem blumenwiesen helfen nicht gegen
hunger an der stelle wir haben ein
reales problem und wir müssen die
agrarpolitik in der agrarpolitik ist
europäisch deshalb betrifft uns das auch
und die niederländer haben das gleiche
problem wie bier und wir sind nicht
gegen umweltschutz das ist doch
vollkommener quatsch aber wir müssen
umweltschutz mit den leuten machen so
dass die prüfe auch weiterhin an ihren
30 eine existenz so sehr auf bio auf öko
auf wie sie sagen überspitzt auf die
blumenwiesen sodass man existenzen aus
dem weg dass mein lebensmittelkrisen aus
dem blick verliert naja preise bilden
sich angebot und nachfrage und in das
magazin daher schieben darf und wenn man
das angebot verknappt steigen die preise
und das merken wir im moment in einer
art und weise wo ich glaube dass wir uns
das nicht weiter leisten können uns
intensiv gedanken darüber machen müssen
und das und das tue ich wie man
tatsächlich auch das angebot ausweiten
kann und wenn man bestimmte flächen
nicht bewirtschaften möchte muss man
andere flächen aber umso intensiver
bewirtschaften und den landwirten dafür
die mittel an die hand geben so ganz
elegant jetzt den ampeln
landwirtschaftsminister zu mir aus der
schusslinie genommen indem sie nicht
über los gelobt haben der ist nämlich
genau dabei war im verknappen und wenn
ein landwirt erst blühstreifen an den
klingt super das sind aber hektar
weideland die aus der bewirtschaftung
herausgenommen prima sache als die igel
drin also insekten alles toll jetzt
möchte sie mir zwei prozent brachflächen
wo einfach nur alles liegt nichts berger
wird kann man auch machen wir haben
gleichzeitig ein ziel bis 20.30 uhr 30
prozent ökolandwirtschaft machen muss
man wissen öko landwirtschaft hat einen
ertrag von etwa 60 der konventionellen
wir verklappen selbst das
nahrungsmittelangebot kein problem
europas reich europa kann lebensmittel
importieren gern sogar weizen aus afrika
die verrecken dort und warum man wir
importieren das und nimmt gerne als
viehfutter ist ein komplexes system aber
wenn ich herrn als die mir höre habe ich
eigentlich immer so den eindruck dass
wir eigentlich irgendwie so eine
idyllische landwirtschaft von vor 100
jahren gerne haben möchten präsentieren
auf einer großen wiese gut geht die
blumen sprießen und der ertrag spielt
eigentlich keine rolle das ist längst
nicht mehr so ich hab da mal ne frage
ist würde ich einfach mal passieren die
grünen stellen 25 prozent der reeder das
heißt 75 prozent der wähler die nicht
grün gewählt haben werden jetzt in diese
in diese historische zwangsjacke
gesteckt ja wir müssen jetzt alle also
das alles mitmachen und ein sehr kluger
politiker der beste den wir jemals hat
aus meiner sicht hat mal gesagt in der
krise beweist sich der charakter jetzt
sind wir in einer nie dagewesenen krise
ist es nicht jetzt zeit vielleicht jetzt
mal genau zu überlegen aber bestimmte
maßnahmen auch wenn man sich dafür
ausgesprochen hat ich jetzt vielleicht
mal zurück zu fahren und wird wohl und
vor allen dingen die den wunsch
natürlich gar nicht sagen dass sie
menschen dazu essen auf dem tisch hat
dass man jetzt vielleicht war von
zurückgeht ich meine die grüne partei
war ja früher auch die gesagt hab kein
kläger jetzt wird ja auch jetzt auf
waffenlieferungen für gut geheißen ja
keine ahnung kernenergie soll weg es
gibt viele dinge die vielleicht jetzt
mal vielleicht mal noch überdacht werden
müssten auch den abbau von irgendwelchen
grünflächen wo wir nahrung die wir ja
wenn ich höre wenn wir in afrika
dahinter wegnehmen und die vereine hat
sind wir denn für ein land wenn wir das
was ist das denn bitte für eine
heuchlerei als beweis doch bitte mal
jetzt in dieser krise den charakter und
überlegt noch mal ideologische gedanken
und programme die vielleicht jetzt erst
mal zurückgestellt werden müssen damit
hat weniger menschen in unserem land
hungern und woanders auf und vor allem
vielleicht menschen nicht unbedingt
frieren oder kalt duschen müssen kinder
und alte menschen zum beispiel sind
alles schöne herstellt kann man sich
schöne profilieren und wichtig tun
kriegen auch wunderbar aber in der
realität sind sie nicht umsetzbar
jeweils nicht so wir wollen alle sparen
wir müssen nicht jeden tag duschen aber
er später erspart mir solche
klugscheißer reihen ich kann sie nicht
mehr hören nach neuen gar nicht in der
schutz bei deckt alle kinder die in
unserem land missbraucht werden und
schutz vor opferschutz geht und da
könnte die zahl auf tisch legen da
würden euch allen die ohren schlackern
und deshalb sage ich bin dann muss man
auch mal vielleicht mal demut wieder
herausholen und den eid den mann
geschworen hat für dieses land auf
dieses land für die menschen vielleicht
auch mein leben dass meine mein wunsch
ich weiß nicht ob du einfach ein
wunschtraum ist aber er kämpft dafür und
natürlich weiterhin tun hat hier aber
anders verhält ich glaube auch die
landwirte würden sich menschen wie sie
wünschen damit machen die partei
ergreifen und kämpfen und scheuklappen
brauchen sie mir nicht vorzuwerfen was
aber kommt das ist vollkommener quatsch
an der stelle natürlich müssen wir jetzt
in dieser krise auch ist also die ein
oder andere illusion überwinden und
wir tun das hier ein bisschen
unabhängiger werden von energie das ist
die erste erkenntnis die wirtin dieser
woche angegangen aber da müssen wir ja
und hatte am ende wir müssen auch den
zweiten und den dritten schritt gehen
davon bin ich fest überzeugt und am ende
des tages bedarf es dann keinen
unterschied machen wo der kubikmeter gas
oder oder dass die kilowattstunde strom
herkommt und wenn die sage eintritt die
im moment viele prophezeien dass ende
juli einfach die gasleitungen nicht mehr
gespeist werden das noch stream 1 leer
bleibt dann werden wir neue debatten
führen müssen und dann werden wir kein
gas mehr verstromen
haben wir sie jemanden wie herrn stahl
derweil unter weil die fische auch nach
folter und nicht antwort von millionen
von menschen und taschengeld ich wünsche
mir immer leute die mitten aus dem leben
kommen im parlament egal in welcher
partei da bin ich vollkommen legal der
bundestag kann sehr viele leute
gebraucht den laden einfach mal
aufmischen das ist viel zu ruhig wenn
sie die regierungsbefragung angucken
oder die befragung des kanzlers das ist
also im prinzip
gleichenfeier was da passiert jeder weiß
hier jeder weiß
dass war das war sehr hart aber wir sind
durch die befragung von merkel einiges
gewöhnt gewesen und olaf scholz top das
jetzt noch hansel parlaments die erste
ganz geguckt
das ist ja teil des problems der
teilhabe und dem raum vielleicht müssen
wir anders diskutiert aber was
vielleicht müssen wir debatten im
bundestag anders geführt werden dann
hätte ich ja eigentlich ein londoner
unterhaus das halten sie nicht wieder
aus möchte solche grund was mir aber
aufgefallen ist dass wir gerade jetzt
vor kurzem habe darüber berichtet oder
andere auch eine krisensitzung hatten
und kein einziger minister in der krise
unseres landes anwesend war es war die
länderminister bank unterlassen muss ich
schon sagen ist ein schlag ins gesicht
aller bürger die in diesem land zurück
stecken sollen entbehrungen laufen
sollen wenn die minister die 25 männer
im monat bekommen ihren arsch noch nicht
weil dahinter wegen wo sie für dieses
land und diese liebe einstehen müssen
das ist fakt und dafür sollten sie sich
schämen in grund und boden
diskussion das ist ja heutzutage so man
hat eine meinung entweder als politiker
wirtschaftsmanager oder was und dieser
weg wird gegangen und wenn ich aber
zwischendurch merke ich bin hier falsch
es gibt vielleicht andere optionen
bessere möglichkeiten ein mann zieht das
ding bis zum ende durch
man hat dann angesichts verlust aber
keiner würde doch sagen wann ich würde
die die lage hat sich geändert wir
switchen umfasst so gut gemacht das ist
würde auch jeder würde sagen
vorgeworfen naja warum
was wir dann nicht sehen ist der richtig
breite mittelbau ein
familienunternehmen an kleinen
unternehmen an kleinen ackerbau
betrieben oder bauernhöfen die das so
machen also die kommen gar nicht drum
rum ein familienbetrieb kann sich nicht
leisten wir konzern linie einfach durch
die politik vor dass sehr viele kleine
wie die sieht man eben meistens nicht
die machen das aber bei einem
großkonzern ich meine daimler hat erst
ein riesen internationalisierungs
kampagne gefahren hat chrysler gekauft
war alles mist milliarden verbrannt
wurde dann wieder auseinander dividiert
also ein schwenk um 180 grad gut da geht
dann meinen konzernchef irgendwann in
rente nimmt ein paar hundert millionen
abfindung mit und das war es dann aber
auch eigentlich sind das so fundamentale
management fehlleistung dass man darüber
über ganz andere haftungsbedingungen
nachdenken müsste aber gut dass nahrung
wird in der politik nicht so gedacht
dass man mal links und rechts gucken
warum bin ich als parteien in meinem
system gefangen in meinem parteibuch
warum kann ich nicht sagen mission